I have always for years
now this they'll laugh at this I hope
thought that
the best looking dude and I'm very
strong heterosexual but the I love the
preface yes he is my what do you call
that ganger
doppelganger who said that that was Alex
oh yeah yeah
doppelganger who Brad Pitt Brad Pitt you
bet Brad Pitt
no no I've never well I'm telling you I
never met him I'm afraid I'm afraid and
I always tell everybody oh you know I
get people say I look like Brett I've
used Brad Pitt's name forever I'm sure
he's heard about it well can we I just
want to see a side by side real quick
because I just need a room oh it's not
going to be good I just need to recap oh
yeah there we go there we go
[Applause]
that's not a good look
it's a great that's my life as my wife
says I'm stood
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]